I auditioned for cats the the musical
phenomenon that was cats the movie
yeah let me just show you the dance The
Dance Part of That audition was was
something to behold uh because I think I
think I remember sanding in like a
waiting room and all the guys and girls
that were in there were all ballet
dancers and of course I'd never had any
ballet training before so what did you
do well they they tried to teach me
ballet within a minute and a half yeah
[Applause]
so I thought oh I'm gonna be a cat I'm
gonna be a cat you know like you know
the whole camera you know but no there
was none of that there was basically a
guy who was in this the audience huge
stage and this guy came out the audience
was like let me let me let me teach you
let me teach you the dance so there you
know five six seven eight
oh